president biden is expressing support
for demonstrators in cuba
after thousands of people took to the
streets in one of the country's biggest
protests in decades
they are angry over the worsening
economic crisis on the island
now this comes as the biden
administration reviews its policy
toward the communist nation including
whether to ease or maintain
economic sanctions manuel mahorcas is in
miami with more on this story good
morning to you manny what has been the
reaction there
well good morning gail the protests have
continued here in miami's little havana
neighborhood
but because the internet has been cut in
cuba it's hard to know the extent of
additional protests there
what is clear is the situation is
putting pressure on the biden
administration to define its
cuba policy they call on the government
governor cuba to refrain from violence
their attempts to silence the voice of
the people president biden on monday
said the u.s stood with cuban protesters
i don't think we've seen anything like
this protest
in a long long time
the comments came a day after thousands
of cubans poured into the streets
protesting against the communist
government triggered by food shortages
rising prices and the government's
response to rising covet infections
thousands in miami have joined in
solidarity
havana born damir perez came to florida
a decade ago
and says he's optimistic the protests
will fuel
change we've been fighting this fight
for a long time now we have never seen
it in 62 years
of dictatorship in cuba but in havana
it was mostly quiet again by monday
police were seen patrolling the streets
cuban authorities appear to have blocked
access to social media sites like
facebook
whatsapp and instagram dozens of people
have been reportedly arrested in the
protests
including journalists many demonstrators
were also injured in clashes with police
and pro-government activists
president miguel diaz-canel blamed
cuba's economic turmoil on the u.s trade
embargo
the biden administration pushed back on
any notion the u.s was responsible
for the protest these are protests
inspired by the harsh reality of
everyday life
in cuba not people in another country
one indication of the mounting
discontent in cuba is the op tech
uptick i should say in the number of
migrants arriving here in florida
by vote risking their lives despite no
longer having an automatic
legal pathway to remain in this country
adriana manny thank you you know one of
the
things people were chanting the
protesters in manny's peace was
patria evita which is homeland and life
and that's a play
on the communist slogan patriarch
which is homeland or death so people are
saying it's not enough just to have our
homeland
we need to live well you've been there
yeah i
reported on the normalization of
relations in 2014 and 2015 for cbs
and things are so different now because
3g arrived at the country in 2019 and
that's allowed people to spread these
messages to go out to the street in
protest
that's also why the government's cut the
internet in response